I blame the Drone flyer because what
they had to do is as an expert drone
flyer they had to put it low to the
ground right yeah you put it low to the
ground
they can't they can't go that low
exactly and then do you think the CIA
guy who's on his like he's got like an
antenna from his iPhone he's just like
he's one of these guys oh
[Music]
so do you guys see this drone that got
shot down not exactly it got brought
down by a Russian
um uh fighter plane but it was an
American drone right and the Russian
plane
kind of does a sick move where it fuel
dumps on top of the Drone so it like
wigs out the Drone sensors or some [__]
and then the Drone gets brought down
whoa so they still have all the
information they have all the [__]
exactly they didn't destroy the Drone
they brought it down aren't they saying
that they were harassing the Drone
so yeah exactly I mean they're the
they're harassing the Drone the U.S
state Department released the defense
department released the video showing
the harassment which is just the
Russians like
they fart they pissed on it it was like
a bird that went back yeah like they did
two passes at it the first time they
missed it with the fuel dump and the
second time dead on them and he was
running out of fuel on the way back huh
probably probably got [__] himself
on the way back I blame the Drone flyer
because what they had to do is as an
expert drone flyer they had to put it
low to the ground right yeah you put it
low to the ground
they can't they can't go that low and
then do you think the CIA guy who's on
his like he's got like a Nintendo from
his iPhone he's just like
uh so so the Russians just threw the guy
like an awards ceremony oh [__] wow they
needed this win two pilots yeah yeah for
the su-27 fighter plane
um they're basically just
yeah dude this guy's killing it yeah
he's gonna be very swag well it
humiliated the United States because
like you know we're the big bad
superpower and then we got our drone
taken down yeah I don't want Russia to
win but I do like Underdog moves whoa
right yeah
all right the statement yeah that's a
spicy tape so you're saying you're
betting on Russia no I don't want Russia
to win I don't want it but you always
bet against us yeah yeah yeah
Foundation a big sponsor
happening
ah I just like David and Goliath moments
but I don't take a but my team's always
USA bro USA what if it's Goliath versus
Goliath oh who are you taking in the OG
Goliath
Russia's kind of Goliath huh yeah bro
kills them but it would be China's
military Yeah by far our military
spending's like you nobody could touch
it because ask me how much we spent on
the homeless let's go
that's the military yeah beat those guys
yeah you [__] with us so let me ask you
guys this as a question to the room is
was this an act of War
according to them it wasn't
us I mean because they were like oh with
that drone was manned that's what
they're saying right they're like you
guys are lucky
I feel like it's an active award like
probably 30 years ago yeah now it's like
whatever it's like Downing one of those
food delivery robots the ones that fell
on their own it's like if a Russian guy
went up and kicked it active
I think it would depend where the Drone
was flying so if it's over Russian
airspace
that [__] is mine you know it was
international waters right
oh it's International it's over the
Black Sea in international World well I
thought they owned the Black Sea no oh
no internet is definitely International
so them dumping on fuel on it like that
doesn't it's not bad for the environment
is that really an attack what about what
about the poor ocean animals dude what's
going on with those mug seals yeah yeah
see that's why they're biting that's why
they're biting yeah they're pissed no so
it yeah that's that's the question right
it's like okay well they didn't use arms
on the on the that's a cool technology
exactly I feel like that's that's the
scene out of top gun Maverick dude a
little bit
Yeah migs can pull that off why do we
gotta keep roaring man why do what we
gotta keep warring it's like human
nature it has to happen but I don't want
to see it no more man warning no you
just want to see it behind you in
history so I've been what's your perfect
vision all right you want to see endless
evidence of it so the way that I think
we're gonna achieve world peace is is
picture this okay
one government okay one group okay
Oneness everyone has to spend they spend
the same money okay we get a chip on our
hands do we all make the same one and
then
um
yeah and we're just one so how can you
fight how can you War if you're just one
country so like World War One brain too
you don't have your own thoughts because
you have the chip yeah yes and then we
can use
AI to work together to work together I
love it world peace I think you figured
it out I think we're good to go imagine
like think think about all the food that
you don't like and then it's like oh
everyone doesn't like it too and then
now that if it doesn't exist anymore yep
so sick easy yup
that's it but I would obviously be
pretty high up there so I could make the
decisions
Now High key I'd want to be in the
government right yeah yeah I don't know
I'd have to be yep yeah yeah yeah
because then you're the one everybody
works in the government yeah well no
just me and my friends though if we were
like one world government why would you
want to be a would it end up like
Divergent
I tell you one thing if we in government
gonna have some guys Rebel and they're
gonna start their own faction oh and
then War's gonna happen again
[Laughter]
we'll never have peace I don't think we
will man yeah Avatar 3 might might you
guys think that Colleen knows that her
car got stolen or should we do you think
that like everybody's car should get
stole
but what if we have one government One
World Government and everyone has a car
so you wouldn't need to steal a car
because everyone just borrows each
other's cars yeah but then somebody's
gonna be like I don't just want one car
right that's what I'm saying and I'm I'm
more on that yeah and I like his car
better than the car that I have exactly
I ain't trying to fight it but what if
we just have one
like we wipe out all the one car we all
shoot the whole world yes
yeah just one they're like oh we can't
use a car why it's in Alaska today
they're like oh yeah when is la gonna
get the cargo I'm late for work because
when it's L.A so as a whole state
you know what one car if we had the
Canadian military set this up it's
probably feasible because they're used
to that yeah they're like we have like
maybe four tanks and we gotta cover a
lot of Border they know how to share
four things they know how to nurse they
know how to move it around yeah
corner
and I just go clockwise yeah all right
rotate that's where all the action is
that the corners right and like hey
there's a [__] moose over here we
think it's maybe a national security
threat yeah all right we'll be there in
about 18 hours all right the Moose took
out one of our tanks yeah it could be me
so it's an attack it's a threat if it's
mises yeah robotic animals in the woods
would be mental yeah have you seen the
dog ones the dog robot the ones that
they kick over and they pester and they
make bad memories about boss Dynamics I
love it you think that it's like to the
public America's like oh that's not an
active War but then in the office
they're like exactly it's [__] odd
bro yeah I feel like we look a little
[__] made dude right I do think we'd be
looking why would we release this video
by the way we got dunked on kind of
right our drones should not be getting
jet fuel on them it's like it's March
Madness and we just saw someone shoot
his jump shot at the buzzer and then
then our team releases
maybe it's just misdirection
we're like yeah focus on the fact that
we let you do this and then we're doing
something else U.S government I would be
like they took the bait and that's
that's right idiots that's a news if
everything it works that way that'd be
pretty funny like even when they're uh
they found the weather balloon and
they're like all right we're gonna act
like we don't know how to shoot the [__]
down for like six days so keep missing
play along with me I don't know because
I'm gonna tell you I don't know what it
is I'm sure they got some back end [__]
that they gotta figure out you know what
I mean they got some other stuff the
scariest thing would be that if we have
something like Mega weapon that we're
acting like we don't have that's the
scariest thing that'd be tough big boy
yeah yeah fat man or whatever it's
called what is it what is it Batman
what's that what's Batman that's the
Manhattan Project what's that oh that's
what they called it and there's the the
nuclear bomb they should have called a
fat man from the top I thought we
already have a lot of nuclear missiles
it's a big secret the way that the nuke
debuted to people then is what if
there's a what if there's a thing now
top secret oh [__] it can destroy a
whole city I mean Ohio I mean there's
some right I mean the train there's all
kinds of weird stuff I heard there's
weather there's weather attacks
happening see that that's cool now we're
talking because the Chinese are like
haha I'm California never rains we're
gonna give you all the rain and
California is like we've been needing
this [__] [__] and it's acidic you know
what I mean oh yeah that's true they're
like you get all the rains your
drought's gone but the water is [__]
up bro it's carbonated it's like oh yeah
is this sand sparkling yeah Asian
inspired salsa
foreign
[Music]